and house arena how's the family doing
out here well things have seemingly
changed as Bradley Cooper and Irina
Shayk have split after four years
together this according to reports
People magazine was first to break the
news that the pair have officially ended
their relationship and are now amicably
working out how to share custody of
their daughter Aaliyah who they welcomed
in 2017 before they called it quits a
source told ET the pair had been unhappy
in their relationship for some time but
tried to make it work
quote they both want the best for their
daughter but seem to be coming to terms
with the fact that staying together
might not be for the best
the source also revealed that things
were rocky before she started filming a
star is born with Lady gaga I just want
to take another look at you a constant
speculation about his relationship with
the singer didn't make things easier at
home although the source insists his
relationship with Gaga was not the issue
and they had been fighting for quite
some time
et has reached out to both reps for
Bradley and Irina for comments
[Music]